hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer furry's in TV
and I'm here at the University of
Southern California with journalism
professor Robert Hernandez Robert thanks
for talking to us today thanks for
having me
so next semester you are incorporating
Google glass into your curriculum can
you talk about what you plan to do with
this is it more for consumer side that
you're building a new platform for
Google glass are using Google glass in
terms of storytelling techniques what
I'm interested is the storytelling part
of it so we want to create content and
experiences for those who are wearing
glass to try to get you know journalism
and information in a different way so
taking advantage of glasses features for
better for worse it knows where you are
where you are it knows what you're
looking at and has the power of the
internet right all kind of coming
together with the screen there what type
of stories can we tell how can we
optimize our existing news content my
end goal is augmented reality AR
storytelling this technology that's
emerging and glasses is a really great
wearable platform that is very early but
has a lot of potential to do that it's
got a touchable surface here and once I
tap it I can wake it up or I can nod my
head to wake it up and if you can see
the light turns on that indicates that
it's on and that's the way to let people
know that I could be recording things
like that you actually see what I'm
seeing it's transparent you pointed out
that you can see when it's recording so
do you think that all the privacy and
recording consent concerns are
unwarranted I think one of the things
that has happened which is
understandable is a lot of people are
projecting things onto glass they don't
know they haven't played with it they
some people think it's full immersion
these are fantastic while driving I have
a horrible sense of direction so the GPS
and the coroner tells me where to go
it's a lot safer than unlocking my phone
going at the map looking for the map the
other thing is I'm actually happy that
they're having a conversation about
privacy would we have had this
conversation before Snowden in the NSA
would we have had this conversation I
don't know but what it's doing is doing
a couple things that's raising the
awareness that the truth is we don't
have privacy and in public places
all these cameras recording us all the
time so if this is gonna help you
realize and be aware and be a more
engaged citizen great but is this going
to spy on people this worked on spying
on people too this is so early that
people are freaking out about it
proactively banning it from restaurants
you don't want me to be recording you in
inappropriate times
that's that social dynamic that we're
dealing with but the difference is this
is on my face right and you can see that
it's on so your behavior currently will
change when I put that on that's for a
report I have to compensate for that
just like that it's different when
someone brings out a camera or a
microphone or on notepad
and I'm not no journalism takes
different forms depending on the
platform you know print journalists have
to think very differently than video do
you think that glass is just going to be
the next iteration of you know mobile
journalism or is it gonna be something
completely different I do believe and it
sounds crazy Tom but I do believe that
our mobile phones are gonna be outdated
and they're gonna be replaced with
wearables how soon I don't know but it
just makes logical sense and the next
evolutionary step I also think glass is
gonna look like the Zack Morris phone or
the Gordon Gecko phone that old brick
glass which looks sci-fi and dorky at
the same time it's gonna look ridiculous
a couple years down the road the point
of this class is I want to be proactive
about shaping that type of story so if I
know eventually mobile phones are not
gonna be in my back pocket but they're
gonna be on me
all the time whether it's in my face or
the joke that we say the chip in the
brain let's just assume we're gonna live
in the future because we kind of do have
some examples of that and I believe that
journalism is gonna be around maybe not
the newspaper but the content in the
newspaper is gonna be around then why
don't I proactively try to define what
that article looks like so I want to
look at what does NPR look like sound
like feel like in this platform
what does long-form look like what does
a tweet what's that optimize experience
for that is this gonna be a brand new
platform that we have to customize our
content to that doesn't necessarily
scale and really at this time we want to
take it slow but I would want to
experiment and figure that out take a
picture AR storytelling is like I said
it's my end goal and one of the factors
the VAR is full immersion not like VR
full immersion that everything is made
up but AR augmented reality is I define
it as real life enhanced by digital and
so glass has a small screen in the upper
corner it's as if you're holding your
phone out at arm's length that's how
much real estate it takes up right it's
not a full immersion type of thing so
with that small screen I'm trying to
think of what are the type of stories I
can tell that are useful and appropriate
to interrupt your life and give you
bite-sized information as the glasses
become more common with consumers it
might facilitate citizen journalism do
you think that that will take over
should journalists like myself be scared
for our jobs that's the same thing when
phones came out and when camcorders came
out I'm sure actually I'm not sure about
the camcorders it's just more point of
views more data more information being
collected and I think a journalist this
job is to not only create that content
but also navigate through that stuff to
point out and amplify the voices that
need to be amplified and those that are
spreading misinformation
I saw one person say that glass is the
next Gutenberg printing press that's
ridiculous or it's gonna replace
broadcast equipment I don't foresee that
anytime soon I mean it does that have
really good quality but my body is not a
tripod and when I'm talking to you if we
were going to look at the POV shot it
moves around you've referred to yourself
as the mad scientist of journalism sure
I've always nerded out over technology
since I've gotten into it and I'm always
tinkering and messing with tech glass is
just the latest augmented reality social
media code just in general I I'm a
journalist first and a technologist
second but I hijacked technology for
journalism and someone whether I'm
getting paid for it at the University or
elsewhere I'm always tinkering and
trying to figure out how can i how can I
use it so when I got Foursquare I
thought about how can I use this for
journalism I know I can how to use it as
a civilian but as a journalist I use it
completely different Twitter same thing
Instagram vine
trying to think of how can i hack it for
journalism well that was really fun
thank you again for having us thanks for
having me
freezin TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer